[Music]
all right this is going to be another
exciting one where we're going to start
with the photo okay we'll go from there
you already know
i got a rock
um is that a nfd that sold for like 40
million or so oh my god it is isn't it i
bet you it's something it's a rock nft
it is an nfc oh
how much is it valued at
20 grand ooh
30 000. 3 million 300 000 higher than
that lower than that wait higher than a
board eight five hundred thousand three
mil eight hundred thousand one mil what
wow
one is like a meat what does it do it's
a non-possibility [ __ ]
it does matter but this but this is the
tweet that just went out with it
how's your week by at dino underscore
dealer
how's your week mine
i just erroneously listed at ether rock
number 44 for 444
way instead of 444e
bot sniped it in the same block and
trying to flip for 234e in one click my
entire net worth of one million dollars
gone is there any hope am i gonna make
it can snipers show mercy so he he
mistakenly paid that much no he
mistakenly elicited it for less for a
totally different currency than ether
there's apparently high demand for these
already
it's like what happened with the board
ape recently remember you hear about
that guy sold it for like 15 bucks and
yeah it was it was worth like so he
listed it for the wrong
currency there yeah so so way 444 away
is literally point zero zero is like two
cents oh
it's nothing in a box why did he list it
was he drunk he was trying to listen for
444 ether yeah i think he's just
mistaken so i think he was drinking a
bot that was programmed to buy stuff
when they're undervalued just bought it
before he could react you don't interact
with something that expensive
without a clear head like like you know
what i mean
something's going on but there's a lot
of people that make
mistakes but not
[Laughter]
listen
what do you mean joe not me was it me
yeah i'm mr man's risk he's talking
about himself what did you do
i'm talking about the bitcoin guy that
[ __ ] he has a lot in the in a dump
dump site and he's trying to look for
his bitcoin oh that actually makes more
sense
that makes sense because it didn't cost
him anything to do it so he's not like
remembering how much it took to to get
that what made this one worth a million
dollars i don't think i i think
answering that question is the conundrum
of life it's like impossible i mean did
someone previously did he buy it from
someone else why are why is there a
midnight line for jordans it's just
sneakers people love those you could
simplify everything if you want to but
for some reason there's a group of
people who are willing to pay whatever
for whatever scarcity you can say that
about like fine art modern art i mean
just the whole art industry to me it's
the same but but as far as it is it is
but but as far as like the nft
marketplace yeah like what's the what's
the significance of this one in that
[ __ ] is it is it the people behind it
talking about it it could be connected
to some kind of dow you can get into
some certain discord group or club or
physical club so this is like a one-off
this is something or it just is what it
is yeah well it's just it could be just
the first of its kind where it's like
the pet rock but it's like yeah remember
there was a pet rock craze
like what the [ __ ] when i tell people
your financial system is being
replicated on the blockchain i mean all
of it like stuff like this like the pet
rocks all the stupid [ __ ]
that's it it's already here we already
do it all the time everybody it's not
like your grandparents aren't like why
the [ __ ] are people spending money on
this like like already they already are
but now they're asking the questions
about blockchain too it's the same [ __ ]
it is the same [ __ ] so again uh the
blunder meant that this actually sold to
a bot for 444 away which is worth about
0.0012 cents
sharing the display despair online the
collector wrote
exactly what i said earlier how's your
week mine i just erroneously listed
ether rock for 444 way instead of 444
eve
bought sniped it in the same block yeah
yeah i wonder what they got it for
more than [ __ ] 12 cents
less i mean that was
.0012. somebody was just sitting there
[ __ ] f5 in that page waiting to buy
some [ __ ] or they just got completely
lucky there's nfd bots that just cop
things if it's a there's bots in general
that that do those things you know what
i mean the second anything gets listed
at some sort of like shoebox phenomenal
price yeah somebody's already scooping
or flash crashes is there scoop by
blocks is there like a nft for you guys
that are playing around with mts that
you're like you got your eye on and
you're like dude that number i will see
150 of them
it's just lottery tickets for me because
i am using a
still
underutilized blockchain called terror
right so like it's number two total
value locked on all crypto it's in nft
space it's not even close to that so
like for me i'm like well there's that
much visibility now especially with dope
one by one's bitcoin
so
why won't i hold all these lottery
tickets so that's what i've been doing
but at this point in the run i'm not
buying nfts i'm just holding as much
luna as possible however
the ones that i've gotten into it's
really just about making sure that it
has something going for it where
it's not gonna just go away overnight
like there's not somebody gonna pull all
the liquidity out or
um there's a lot of things that can
happen with nmts it's still so early i
don't know enough about nfts to sit here
and 99 percent of nft projects pretty
much are red pools though no that's
right here absolutely rug pulse isn't
necessarily the same as like
uh conniving intentional once everybody
buys we're going to run yeah rug pulls
uh is also kind of categorized as like a
hey this is uh that's my jpeg i'm not
promising anything and everybody's
paying a bunch of money thinking that
there's some sort of speculative concept
that is going to bring them such
overbearing profits in a near
distant future but then when the people
who made it are just like cool now i'm
rich i'm not doing anything else yeah
and they lose interest yeah you know
what i mean that's not really a rug pool
that's just like overvalued that's still
categorized because nobody understands
the speculative nature of things like
energy crypto is already speculative so
much because you only have like two
three four blue chip concepts that
aren't even like fully understood as
blue chip right everything else is
considered speculative because 99 people
don't [ __ ] do any research anyway
yeah and then nfts are even more
volatile right so it's even like 2x to
10x speculative in concept because the
other day a pfp no matter what the [ __ ]
yeah is a
jpeg
no matter how much you spend on it no
matter how [ __ ] sick the company
behind it is if the nfc doesn't
represent something like stock interest
if it's not an actual percentage
investment of the company if you don't
own shares by owning it then you are
technically still owning
a [ __ ] jpeg let's be realistic about
it right like the most realistic we
could be anybody who buys an nft like
99.9 of them can't wait to [ __ ] sell
it for way more than it's worth right
that's the game for the game that's the
whole game yeah so so because of that
all you're doing is buying lottery
tickets so for me i have 155 lottery
tickets and they i spent varying degrees
of whatever the [ __ ] on them whatever
you're willing to say nowhere near five
percent of my stack that's the whole
thing measure risk
uh involve yourself like definitely you
you can involve yourself with different
projects but just measure risk the whole
[ __ ] time don't be stupid don't
leverage trade anything ever
and don't put yours don't open yourself
up to any kind of risk that you're not
willing
to lose at any point because it could
just immediately go away if you're gonna
do that when you're looking for a
specific when you're looking for a
specific nft like what are those
qualities that i know it's random and
it's really speculative is there any
qualities at all that you were like oh
i'm i'm getting this one because of x y
and z honestly i don't know enough about
it yet to know so it's like like look
i've been in crypto for almost 10 years
i know way more about crypto as a whole
nfts are so new i can't claim to know
because i haven't been through nft
cycles yet i don't know less than a year
old of how it gained traction i'm not
gonna sit here and tell anybody anything
about nfps other than
i like the
tech behind entities that true ownership
is is
able to be seen on the blockchain by
everybody everybody knows exactly who
truly owns something if they own that
nmt they truly own it i like that right
but and and
as far as the tech behind it you can use
it for medical records you can use all
for all kinds of real world use cases
that will matter at some point in the
future it's really not ready it's too
early probably for any of that to be
integrated so we're talking about like
right now it's kind of a dot-com bubble
for entertainment it's that's where
we're at we're like mid-90s i can see
nfts being like the digital
like document of a deed or something for
a home or like used in in that but but i
know that like um there's another way
that nfts are being used and it's the
and it's in the form of like a pawn shop
so like let's say
if i have a rolex that i want to
loan on right i could put it into the
nft space and there's already sites out
there where you can basically
get money on that rolex and then it's
collateral yeah as collateral and then
you have to ship it in or sell it you
know and then you get the nft plus the
actual physical rolex that's cool yeah
or in the marketplace like you can put
up the nft and then you know people buy
that rolex from you then you ship the
rolex over and you get the nft as well
yeah and i have a couple hoodies coming
to me that i bought their nfts and then
if you held the nft by a certain point
they snapshot it they snapchat the
address of everybody holding it they
ship them to your actual physical
address once you input it
i don't know that that will be worth
anything i don't [ __ ] know i'm just
there's a project called unisocks that i
have a buddy who bought they're worth
120 000 they're an nft where if you hold
the nft they send you the physical socks
they're just unisocks like like like
uniswap
with unit swap [ __ ] on them
and they're yeah they're worth like six
figures because of a gimmick and you
just don't know so it's all lottery
tickets you just don't know which one's
gonna paint out which ones won't that's
why it's like the dot-com bubble it's
like amazon made it
yahoo made it a couple of them made it
everyone else wiped out you never heard
from everyone thought aol was going to
make it because they had time yeah they
were the biggest boys yeah they got
bought by time warner and got wiped out
of existence same [ __ ] so you just don't
know so it's just too early for me to
sit here and go oh i know about it i'll
tell you this but no it's just about
looking for edges in the market always
look for edges right so what's my edge
right now tara's number two blockchain
all of crypto i've been wearing this hat
since it wasn't even close to that so
like you know what else yeah what else
is going on that's a new hat daddy yeah
you're right the gray one but yeah um
but so what what other edges am i
looking for right in the nft space
uh tara's not even close to being number
two so like maybe
it'll work out that way maybe it won't
who cares
but maybe it will i hope it does but
either way i'm not even spending five
percent of my stack on it so it's i'm
measuring risk for the whole [ __ ]
time if you're not measuring risk you're
exposing yourself to so many l's i can't
even tell you
please just try to try to be careful
about this there is also something
though to the um the understanding of
the culture especially is very apparent
in the speculative nft space though that
like
what is the value of something
and the value should not necessarily be
measured on like what it is of utility
but actually what the demand is people
people oftentimes don't understand the
relativity and the correlation between
why is that thing so valuable well
[ __ ] because the demand is
there it doesn't have to make sense yeah
exactly it's like why is it banksy so
valuable when at the end of the day it's
like a stencil on the side of a wall but
the second he puts something on the
[ __ ] wall that's like a 1.2 million
wall and you're like uh no that's a
graffiti on the wall but we love it
because there's a culture value to it
because there's a demand but it's not
because that graffiti is 10x more
utilization power over
you know this [ __ ]
space whatever the [ __ ] that's on the
wall the delorean is a car that's
largely seen as a failure if you watch
the documentary about it's [ __ ]
amazing but there's such a demand for it
that they're bringing it back now and
like they've already been manufacturing
them from a plant in texas but now
they're actually bringing it back doing
like a completely
um electric delorean because there's
such demand for this [ __ ] it's sweet
nobody buys them
they may they make new factory builds
for like 60k you can just get a brand
new one what
they've offered that for like 20 years
no is the company still around yeah the
guy it got people only buy the old ones
the company got bought by this other
steven nguyen like it's a different one
but you see them you see them everywhere
i see delorean's everywhere it's the
only old way but only the old ones yeah
the new builds nobody buys them because
they're 60 something thousand and you
could get a like when i got mine i got
paid 15k
wow i don't have to really do much to it
other than make it sparklier
yeah so it's like it's not worth 60.
anybody who already knows deloreans and
loves them doesn't want a new one anyway
they want the freaking og one yeah i
don't know if people are gonna buy the
electric one they've been announcing
that electric one for over a decade
and i but it's close yeah that's what
they say if they're really gonna come
out with it but but that's the key right
so so there's always demand for
something even if you think it's not
interesting there's somebody out there
who might want it and if it's scarce
enough hello board apes right like all
this [ __ ] it's just
you trying to mark it you can try to be
better than it yeah but but just about
understanding the market reality
sometimes just knowing that you're not
smarter than the market the market's
smarter than you acquiesce to it accept
it embrace it love it and then try to
figure out what your edge is inside of
it that's how you made so many
millionaires dude that's great advice
look dude that's that's how i win
honestly i measure risk non-stop and i
don't want to expose myself ever except
for to my wife
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you